[Music]
ladies and gentlemen you saw the you saw
the title i was going to do some long
intro but screw it
only fans fake gurus are here and it's
way worse than you think
now before we get started let me just
say uh i found out about this because uh
somebody that i was following said uh
buy my course industry has peaked and
immediately i got curious i see this
this thing
this person says their only fan's course
is fifty percent off i say what's
what's this only fan stuff my mom's
watching and um
you know i i don't get much internet
signal where i'm at so i don't know
what's going on in the world i think
it's some subscription service to like a
backstage pass
thing like for concerts i'm going to be
posting my
hard i was wrong
what are you kids doing these days okay
these people
it's like it's like patreon for
basically adult content and don't worry
it's gonna be a very clean video guys
clean stuff here
but it's youtube baby i follow all the
rules clean channel monetize channel
but the crazy thing is and what shocked
me is that
people are making millions of dollars
doing this just
i i don't know how any of this works i
think we're all like the main
people and only fans are roughly earning
the same i think
at the moment it's like a male a month
and this person says so everyone's gonna
learn how to pay their bills as content
creators
okay ah big red flag number one
the fake gurus this is something i've
noticed actually the fake gurus always
start coming all the core sellers
they all start coming when the
opportunity is no longer that good
ironically like when you saw with amazon
kindle publishing it happens in every
industry
amazon kindle publishing used to be good
then it kind of got a lot harder more
saturated and that's when you see
everyone saying it's so easy to make
money in it same with
amazon third-party selling it got a lot
harder that's when you see the mo
all the courses are coming out saying
it's so easy anytime you see a course
come out about something saying it's a
great opportunity
news flash it was a great opportunity
two years ago three years ago
so i see this and immediately i'm
suspicious but let's let's watch it
together because this is just
we have to talk about it it's incredible
i mean what is going on here the fake
gurus has have invaded everything
hey guys i'm emma and i'm a top one
percent creator on only fans
i've helped people just like where did
you find this rented little house here
you'll make a livable and come on only
parents without even getting naked
you might be wondering how i've done
that so i built off here we go
now the production value is finally
coming and i was worried as a blueprint
that helps you
build manage and grow your only fancy
all while working on your own time
wherever you want
whether you're just starting out
lamborghini
yes okay good good good this is
check check i mean literally you just
can apply it to any industry
clearly you can apply to any industry
process of creating one this program is
for you
i give you all the secret tips and
tricks other creators don't want you to
know that you need in order to be a
successful content creator
so you go to the site and the first
thing you see is how to make five
hundred dollars a day
on only fans without ever getting naked
hey
sign me up uh here's a sneak piece of
how this course will help you get there
already 226 reviews can i see any of
them oh no
no no no i i i can't nothing's clickable
here
three big myths i need to have a big
following you probably do
i need to get nude i need to look like
an insta model
ah listen guys
i'm no expert okay i didn't know what
this site was three minutes ago
but quite frankly if it is what i think
it is i'm pretty sure
all of those are rules actually quite
frankly
but here's what's insulting guys here's
what really pissed me off and made me
need to do this
so it's all the classic you know russell
brunson click funnel stuff right it even
is a click funnel
classic stuff oh testimonials tesla
these are real people real testimonials
right
then you see peek inside the program and
i was obviously curious because i'm
thinking about starting my career
as a feat model actually i was thinking
of putting up some
some some feet pictures and you see this
introduction two minutes long wait what
how does only fans work one minute long
dude this
course has nothing in it it's all
obvious stuff
how do you should you become an only
fans creator let me guess you're gonna
say yes
benefits money how long does it take
like three seconds to sign up
snap a few pics of my feet and then i'm
in
so you go through this thing i was going
through the curriculum and there's
nothing in here
this this person is just literally
selling saying it's the opportunity
great opportunity 500 a day you're
literally selling nude pictures
online how hard is that i mean it's not
so she has nothing on there build your
profile it's like a set up tutorial page
designing your profile starting your
profile bio
fine-tune your bio you're paying 79 for
this establishing a subscription rate
content creation like this is so obvious
and you get to the last part which
should be the most advanced and it's
like
hey maybe you should focus on new
subscribers and content variety
i mean these people have no shame
they're like i'll just charge you for
nothing
build a link tree hey that's a good idea
don't know what that is a link tree just
has a bunch of links it's like you
set it up in three seconds expand your
services
which i guess is like going from a feet
foot model to a hand model
it's like what oh it's so
dumb somebody just read expert secrets
for the first time and decided they need
to get it in on only fans
it's insane like there's nothing in here
i was honestly thinking about buying it
for a meme but
there's nothing i mean even the final
courses are like three minutes long i
think the whole course is like
an hour long of filler content about
basically how to set up a profile
for 79 and the crazy thing is is i bet
this is going to make a ton of money
and you look in here and you go oh
refund policy uh
absolutely no refunds are given
absolutely no exceptions okay
whatever even more reason not to get
this um and then you go to the bottom
it says disclaimer no earnings
projections
promises or representations excuse me
what does this say how to make 500 a day
so obviously i go to enroll right the
earnings disclaimer there is none like
these aren't hyperlinks these are just
like
somebody put it in as text
it's the laziest course i've ever seen
created
ever and it's probably gonna make tons
of money and then here
after saying that oh actually there are
no uh
refunds it says unconditional money back
guarantee well which is it
is it a money back guarantee well let's
check the privacy policy up
uh terms and conditions up this is so
bad
uh this is the worst thing i think i've
ever seen
especially when you consider all these
articles are coming out right now
that this space is so saturated like
according to the new york times they
went from 120 000 content creators in
to more than a million in 2020 so
literally
you 10xed your competition and this
chick is saying
oh it's so easy to do so easy to run
like what are you talking about you have
10 times the competition
and she's not even teaching you anything
listen there are no tricks
you got to just be famous and hot
probably would be my guess wow i just
i'm honestly in disbelief
and i checked their quote tweets i
checked the quote tweets and i said you
know who what are people saying about
this
and uh they're saying not gonna lie i
love this generation of content creators
uh signing up for my first course of
2020 like most of them are positive
people are taking
this ridiculous course which has nothing
in it i mean
literally it's like how to sign up oh
that's the end of the course
want to read the terms and conditions no
no refunds how to make 500
a day not an earnings claim i don't know
it's
drives me crazy i literally swear i i
don't understand the people who spend
money on this stuff i mean it's like
have we not learned
just if you see a click funnels anything
just go
just get out dude it's not it's it's
not gonna be worth it dude that's
basically it i
i wanted to show you guys this let me
know what you think in the comments
below
i mean would you pay for something like
this do you think there's any market for
anything like this
what do you think are you like me are
you a boomer who doesn't know anything
about this world
uh that's it i don't know let me know
what you think in the comments below but
i thought we'd fake guru friday this
girl because
it needs to happen people n can't be
this shameless
it's really terrible anyways yeah that's
basically all for now i don't know
what we're even covering anymore listen
these gurus i i just follow the gurus
guys that's
it that's it okay so thanks for watching
hope you enjoyed
and i will see you on saturday
[Music]